what's the most nervous you've been as a
performer the most nervous I went and
tested for screen tested for Saturday
Night Live and there were five of us and
you may fly to New York get up on stage
and they I knew they were gonna take me
but I didn't realize they were gonna
take me with the actual cameras that
they the big cameras I mean it wasn't
just like a little video thing camera
dude was there with the camera you're on
the monologue stage and at the table was
Tina Fey and Lorne Michaels and two or
three other people and that was so
perfect because you mean there's only
five people watching you even if what
you're doing is hilarious and they're
laughing it's not going to sound like a
wall of love laughter and that year it
was a Fred Armisen Will Forte my good
friend Jeff Davis and another guy I kind
of knew it all five of us you know we
were going up the elevator when I came
in good luck to you know good luck to
you and we were all you know you know
just hey we're in the same boat together
we're all on the same and so we would
all went in and did our audition which I
thought it would pretty well and we're
walking we're walking out and all of us
are getting into the elevator thinking
hey who lets you guys want to go get a
drink
that was crazy that was scary let's go
get a drink and right right as the doors
are closing someone's hand goes tomorrow
to tell him he got it so we could all
bond and have a good time so but that
was super scary but also that like I
mentioned earlier it's not about who's
best it's about what they need at the
time you know did they need a six-foot
to white guy at the time did they need
like it's all about what fits into the
cast at that moment so I feel better
about that now but afterwards I was like
oh I was terrible I must have been
terrible but I wasn't was that another
lesson on maybe not getting your hopes
up too much you know because when you
get an opportunity like that and so
you're it's the the problem with screen
testing for anything in this town and
getting your hopes up is
you have to sign the contract before you
test so you have to sign a piece of
paper that shows you exactly how much
money you're gonna make every month and
how many years that you sign the deal
before you test every one that says for
every sitcom and every every sitcom on
TV every show there's gonna be three or
four people that go in for the network
test and before they do they all go so
you're looking at the money like oh my
god I could have all this money you have
to sign it ten times and initial on
fifteen pages and you turn it in and
then you audition so it's yeah you
shouldn't get your hopes up
you should just do your best but at the
same time it's like oh my god you've
seen all the numbers on that piece of
paper just in the back your mind like I
could really use all that money well
that's where the psychology degree
hopefully yeah right I shoulda listened
if I'd gotten a B I would probably been
happier well maybe I don't know does it
it just it would be very difficult to
see that and then go in and it's tough
yeah yeah the test network testing is
the scariest thing and and of all of the
ones I've tested for SNL was the the
most scariest yeah I think Marc Maron
has a thing to worry oh yeah doing
something and Norma yeah thanks kid
yalta you know he was like waiting
outside bitter about it for years and
then he if you listened to me he had
Lorne on his podcast and they kind of
had a nice what's the word i reconcile
easily i think the nice thing is that
he's upfront about being bitter i know
some people criticize him for that I
think it's great cuz he's just pretty
much vocalizing what a lot of people
think anyway yeah but I know he's been
he's been chastised for that yeah yeah
but it's a great story yeah